a century has passed since Washington
wrote to be prepared for war is the most
effectual means of promoting the peace
in 1897 as assistant secretary of the
Navy TR finds a cause that can help him
redeem his family's honor in Cuba a long
simmering insurgency against the Spanish
colonial empire is coming to a head
TR clamors for military intervention
they're arguing that it's America's duty
to liberate its oppressed neighbors it
was Theodore Roosevelt that was the
first one to say we have a
responsibility to go over and bring
people freedom our freedom and mess in
their affairs and quite honestly that's
the trouble that we have now in the
Middle East that's the trouble that we
have everywhere in the world is that we
were saying we're so great we're gonna
bring this to you that was an invention
of Theodore Roosevelt National Auto what
Teddy needs is a persuasive cause for
attacking Cuba a weapons of mass
destruction argument and he's about to
get one
remember the main probably not most
Americans don't but that's the US
warship that exploded in Havana Harbor
in February 1898 taking 254 American
sailors to their watery graves like 9/11
a century later the tragedy roused
America into vengeful fury and gave
Teddy the cause for war he so
desperately sought even though it wasn't
clear who was the blame created
tremendous war fever in the country and
outrage on the part of TR what this
hideous act against us was needed to be
dealt with immediately Theodore
Roosevelt simply quits being assistant
secretary Naveen says I'm going to warn
TR uses every bit of his political
influence to get a commission as
lieutenant colonel in the first United
States volunteer cavalry regiment
that's cool
he assembled a combination and only
Teddy Roosevelt could have done this a
combination of Ivy League graduates and
cowboys that he had met in the West and
of course they were called the Rough
Riders